welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday there is one sport where
cheating has become an epidemic
the massive popularity of esports as
competitive video gaming
is known has made it fertile fertile
ground that is
for hacking recently china announced a
major esports
cheating bust lucy craft reports from
osaka japan
it was game over for what chinese
authorities called the world's biggest
gang of video game hackers
10 were arrested for selling cheat
software used in best-selling game
titles like call of duty
luxury cars were among the assets seized
from an illicit enterprise ranking in
more than
70 million dollars such cheating
syndicates and video game analysts
circuntoto
have long operated with impunity you
know they're extremely professional if
you look at you know if you look at some
of the website offerings
you know they have shopping carts they
have pricing lists
you know they have customer service
they're like amazon
yeah like amazon exactly yes some of
these companies are raking
millions and millions of dollars in
revenue each month the scale is really
unbelievable in some cases
and so are the profits china's crackdown
reveals the dark side of competitive
video gaming
where top stars playing solo or on teams
command
seven figures online gaming grabs so
many eyeballs it's become a political
tool
this is dangerous last year
representative alexandria ocasio-cortez
live streamed herself playing on the
twitch gaming platform
hundreds of thousands tuned in japan's
first dedicated esports hotel
opened last year in the western city of
osaka
hotel manager takahiro shimamoto said
most of our adult customers check in
friday night
and play all weekend long he meant that
literally
sardine-like bunks bathed in game arcade
lighting
are available upstairs but often go
begging as customers totally immerse
in multiplayer gaming for those of us
who don't have lightning fast reflexes
it's easy to see why cheating is so
irresistible
instead of getting crushed by the
competition cheats give you a
sharpshooter's aim
and the ability to see through walls
like superman in japan
esports lacks the astronomical growth of
neighboring south korea and china
but even here online gamers are known to
take shortcuts
when we first opened we caught three
cheaters the manager said
this year close to half a billion fans
are forecast to watch esports
with revenues on track to top 1 billion
dollars
vanquishing the industry's cheating
scourge will be front
and center for cbs this morning saturday
lucy craft osaka
it's amazing the amount of money
involved but when you see how obsessed
kids are yeah why they
and adults and adults
can't get off the video game the switch
before the before the show it's like
is he talking about